we have a carbon life form bias in other
words do we sort of have this
predisposition that life must have
evolved elsewhere in the universe as it
did on Earth in terms of entirely based
on carbon and so-called organic
chemistry yes we do have a bias however
it's quite interesting because if you
look at the Earth like for example
silica just thinks that people talk
about you know instead of carbon that
you could use we have that on the earth
there's actually more silicate on the
earth than there's carbon it's just
locked in rocks and the problem is it
doesn't make gases very easily either
you have to go actually very high in
temperature to have a silica sio2 for
example and so the question really comes
down to under what condition is carbon
and water your best bet and this
habitable sound that we have to find is
basically for that best bet the solvent
being water and then the backbone
probably being carbon